wir sprechen über einen tiefen politik
sumpf offenbar und stellen uns die frage
steckt der kanzler steckt olaf scholz da
sogar mit drin in diesem sumpf in
hamburg es geht nicht nur um den kanzler
es geht primär um johannes kahrs der war
viele viele jahre der chef haushälter in
der spd im bundestag mächtiger mann ex
abgeordneter aus hamburg also einer der
sich einst kate gekümmert hat und bei
ihm bei ihm haben die ermittler nun in
einem bankschließfach sehr viel geld
gefunden
200.000 euro was ist das für kohle bei
johannes kahrs woher kommt dieses geld
alle zucken bloß mit den schultern wo er
soviel kohle her hat hat das was
möglicherweise mit dem comic skandal zu
tun dem skandal der auch die hamburger
warburg-bank ja längst erfasst hat und
dann wird's spannend denn die beiden die
kannten sich natürlich gut johannes
kahrs und olaf scholz beide hamburg
beide mächtige politiker dort aus der
stadt und beide auch vom
untersuchungsausschuss dort mit blick
auf diesen comic skandal der kanzler
muss nächste woche da wieder aussagen
dann wird spannend sein was ja auch zum
fall cast zu sagen hat und ob er sich
überhaupt mal wieder an was erinnerte
bisher war es im untersuchungsausschuss
in hamburg ja so bei comics meistens
schulter zu meistens konnte man sich
irgendwie komischerweise an nichts
erinnern
[Musik]